hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Spooky's House of
jump-scares the final levels my mic is a
little bit off don't mind me at all
nothing weird happened don't ask any
questions don't write anything weird in
the comments below so here we go back
down into the depths we're gonna finish
this case you didn't know that wait am I
where I need to be oh why was that just
a delayed reaction or didn't want me to
go back first I think there's something
suspicious going on in this place not
that there was any reason to think there
was anything specific [ __ ] is happening
already
I'm just a crazy person who's a glutton
for punishment in him ready oh there's
new ok hello that was not new that was
not new at all I don't know why I
thought this was new this absolutely
unknown a new that there could possibly
be the only thing I kind of noticed is
that it gets darker a little farther on
than it used to may be but then again
maybe I'm just suspicious for no reason
at it oh oh it's coming up I have
noticed though like the 10 level there's
new things that pop up so I imagine that
410 is gonna have someone real sort of
new oh I was right threshold of
consciousness what does that mean
well hello there are you lost little one
no I'm fine I'm fine thanks
you're actually animated it's weird
whoa hi this place can help those who
are ready they expect turmoil more than
you are using for them you soon wouldn't
I just go through I went through an age
of turmoil endless turmoil we're ready
but expect turmoil more than you are
using more than I'm used to all right
then what does that mean huh
oh you weren't kidding about more than
I'm used to
hello okay free insane are we well I'm
guessing this is just totally sane and
normal I'm glad I came to this
existential crisis so there's some text
on the ground over there
hang on divs like Oh Oh kitty cat did
you do this the weird sub two sides of
the same coin knowing your projections
and then help me machine three okay why
is that pointing at me are those
dangerous
I imagine that those are kind of
dangerous and I'm pretty sure that the
things that the cat is saying to me are
probably important II Matthew here
serves is hurt as well but be careful
not to lose your
hey be a part of something become more
than yourself follow the group put on
your mask does that even mean
why do I hear a phone then real life is
that fake life presenting this YouTube
life what is real life
bla bla bla existential crisis what do
we have here oh it's just blood I
thought that was riding on the ground
this doesn't seem very cheerful hi stark
in here did you cause all that blood is
that your blood is on my blood no in
your shed and greatly love you but be
ready to see what you'd rather not be
what I'd rather not be I'd rather not be
dead how about that reminds me of level
from cry oh oh my goodness the walls are
covered in raspberry jam oh no I'm all
out of bread cuz I burned it all whoa
okay did I turn into a monster is that
what happened here this - what is that
Oh what okay I'm on it I'm on it I'm on
it
oh I thought that face I was on a
friendly face yeah
what is hey how's it going there
alrighty then
hey how're you good how's the neighbor
how's the family
oh great great good good and great I
don't know what's happening out but I
think we've descended into several
levels of Hell cuz everything seems to
be a bit different layout than what it
was before and they're these weird low
kick you seem to be shape-shifting quite
a bit here
okay then why why is all this happening
that's the biggest question that I have
why why am I here why am i diving deeper
into this place why are all these
experiments happening here and I don't
even think they're experiments at this
point I couldn't move there for a second
but that's okay
I think like this game the game actually
as a whole is like a combination of
various horror games of the past but
like the story is weird because it
doesn't make any sense it doesn't seem
to be connected but I'm hoping at the
end of it it's gonna be connected
somehow that it's gonna be explained I
can't turn very well goddamn mouse on a
couch you gotta find a better way I'm
gonna play five nights at Wario's again
I'm gonna need to find a better way I
think I can but I don't know right now I
just kind of want it what the hell
happened am i turning into such a
monster that I can see through the wall
okay well I guess we're back to normal
then oddly enough
why what was the point of all of that
was hardened hardened to me hi I heard
many things none of which I liked so you
back off there Sonny I'm gonna happen
I've got that tingling feeling in the
back of my brain that something is gonna
happen I was gonna say anything else
really quiet like it was noisy and now
it's really quiet I hate when games get
really quiet okay
yeah yes was gonna be very gonna play
huh
this is what you're gonna do huh at
least I don't have to go backwards
anymore said markiplier immediately
before he had to start going backwards
again because that douche is chasing him
maybe maybe that's a weird thing like I
mentioned this before in the last
episodes I don't know what its gonna do
like it's not the scariest game in the
world I will readily admit that it's not
buy something scariest but goddamn its
mysterious ding ding God that that seems
to be the most popular pattern so I kind
of just default it but goddamn I don't
know what don't know what is gonna do
hey I'm just suspicious okay I really
got nothing else to say besides what
you've already seen I'm just kind of
waiting for the moment to arrive so
anyway how is all of your day great good
do you guys know how many levels are
actually are in this game if it actually
is randomizer if it maybe set out all
straight one shot that I don't know I
don't know some people were saying maybe
500 levels in the comments last time but
I don't know how many people have
actually gotten to the bottom of this
whole game I mean seems pretty cut and
dry so far ah damn shut up and I still
haven't gotten back to that one same
long hallway that oh god it's not the
same long hallway is it I just have okay
good good good good good
yeah I still haven't gotten to that one
long hallway that killed me last time I
don't even know why it killed me last
time whoa whoa whoa whoa I thought it
was closed up for a second there yeah I
don't even know why he killed me last
time what was the circumstance for me
going into one of those I donno
and again I don't know much also what
was with the cat I notice that the cat
is kind of a theme I noticed the things
on the ceiling now like the cat is it
the poster that might be the same cat I
don't know if it's exactly the same cat
with so similar cat to the poster okay
things are happening I not you I don't
know if they're related I don't know
spooky in the cat or somehow
tangentially related or if they're like
two heads of the same coin like the cat
said maybe I'm spooky maybe I'm really
the ghost I'm going through my own house
to see if I can survive maybe reclaiming
my spirit no the way we're gonna find
out soon enough I'm approaching 500 I'm
actually by the time you see this
actually be on my way to pax right now
cuz I'm gearing up for it now I don't
know I'm actually cutting it close I had
to deal with a lot of stuff today
damnit come on get it to me there we go
sorry about that
I keep getting caught up in those
because I need to hear it I mean I have
not been playing with headphones like I
have in the past and I kind of miss it
because I I can't exactly blast the
sound in my ears and pick up every
little noise that comes by but either
way I'm gearing up for PAX right now and
I may not like I'm hoping because I got
a pre record everything by when I'm gone
because you can't record it on there I'm
hoping that I'm gonna be able to get 10
videos out every day now as I'm saying
this right now I'm planning on getting
all of those videos recorded in time
however however however
yeah damn it god I hate these so much
it's just annoying hey okay now I'm
planning to get ten done but if I can I
damn I'll lose out on my thing but I
mean it'll probably be a little
understandable because I'll be at a
convention meeting you guys so that's a
good expenditure of my time I mean you
guys understand right I'm trying I love
you guys so much it's just wish I could
make you happy every day but I can't
always do it but I try just in case I
can just know that I'm gonna be doing it
Oh from now on if I can only get one
video a day for the five days that I'm
gonna be gone because I'm leaving
tomorrow the Thursday with you hello yep
here do energizer bunny stars except you
jelly little one
okay bye spooky password is cheese I
love cheese I'll try this door
apparently is that a motor I can't go
Heather
damn it you son of a [ __ ] you think it
was that
what's with the scratchy scratches if I
go back I can't go back okay well
it literally is only one choice
it looks good it looks what okay so she
diverted me onto a different path
what does that mean wait help room 23
what the Frick
where's a bunch of bull why you can't
put me all the way back to room 55 it's
a bunch of bull crap what you think I
gotta go through it all again eyes gotta
be some trick oh this is some Bologna
here what wait a minute what that guy's
not supposed to be here my god soundly
not supposed to be what's going on you
can't just put me maybe I should look
[ __ ] to you what can I release twice
Exit Through express what oh okay maybe
I should look at oh you can see that
express tunnel Express tunnel out of
this place maybe huh come on give it to
me baby go away baby give it to me give
it to me hard
hello can actually modify house layout
damn it excess specimen days this
doesn't help me at all that guy God that
guy was creepy Hill but this doesn't
help me oh maybe I wasn't supposed to be
here maybe this is another random
generator a room 513 ok I'm back on
track good good good good good good good
good so spooky trying to get me off
track but spooky failed now I'm on my
way I don't know if I'm eating close to
the end but it feels like I must
considering what just happened maybe
maybe not maybe maybe I'm just shouting
into a camera alone in a room because
I'm just sad recording late at night
trying to appease the masses
he's gotta be some way that there could
be a code entered to change the layout
of that house has got to be there's got
to be something to it it wouldn't be
there if it wasn't absolutely something
that could eventually be triggered maybe
hey I did it okay finally god damn those
are just a pain I just want to get
through this I've got a lot more to
record get me to the end of it already
that is one thing about this game that I
don't like it is a bit of a treachery
like the majority of the rooms that you
go through aren't actually rooms that
are important unless I'm totally
mistaken and each room tells a story
they all seem to be very very
repetitious and I mean that does serve
to give an enormity to the dungeon
itself but it also detract from the
experience in that I feel like I'm
wasting time most of the time this is
slightly different I do notice that the
rooms up getting new now because they're
so later in the save scene just slightly
different but I don't know cuz I've seen
everything so much I don't know if it's
some of the same some are different some
are good some are bad why does you want
from me how can I get out of here why do
I have to trudge my way to 550 and 600
by appeal to 600 now I'm gonna lose my
mind lose my goddamn mind I probably do
don't I probably do great whoa wait a
minute I've been here before but only
once
oh no wait no it's the wall of things I
may be a vendor before
never mind false alarm XO this one's
locked this time thank you I got excited
for nothing
whoa whoa wait a minute
please tell me this is important don't
be just another god damn it oh wow for a
while I thought I had really escaped
this place but despite the trees and the
flora I think this is actually just
another room I did however find deer so
I might at least get to eat they make
some strange sounds oh are you the same
guy that died before cuz that'd be cool
I guess is that the deer you killed
great you least you giving me something
new oh [ __ ] I dig it all right whoa whoa
no I don't know what they are but those
are definitely not deer
I tried sneaking up on one the other day
to kill for food but it saw me as soon
as I got close those barely able to get
away from that thing man's a board up
most of them hopefully I can find
another way out of here
apparently not cuz I bet that's you dead
good golly
[ __ ] those deer Oh an axe can I have
that axe picked up flick the swing Oh
ain't that cool I ain't good
ping ping ping ping thank you yeah you
want some yo what's up brah whoa Udyr a
mess up I'm just gonna go around you
there you go turn it off ah ah Kelly I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die I can't die not
yet ah oh God
dammit dammit dammit dingus damn it damn
it all to hell damn damn damn okay I'm
out of time for this part I got to move
on to the next one I gotta get episodes
out I apologize with visa shorter it's
not I see you right there it's perfectly
normal sighs but I'm gonna finish this
up in the next episode get me those ten
episodes I need for this weekend so
thank you all someone for watching click
the end of days more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
chica chica